allô oui bonjour c'est la bibliothèque
du chéné rocancourt les appels
s'enchaînent à la bibliothèque du chéné
rocancourt depuis mai les chaînés
courtois qu'ils ne peuvent pas se
déplacer bénéficient gratuitement du
portage de livres à domicile
on appelle ça un portage plus qu'une
livraison parce que le but aussi c'est
de rompre l'isolément de la personne
d'avoir un moment d'échangés de
sociabilité avec elle alors dans le
contexte sanitaire actuelle c'est un peu
limité on fait une livraison pas de la
porte
mais d'idées à terme dans un contexte
sanitaire normal c'est qu'on aura un
temps d'échangé avec la personne
ça pourrait être un échange autour de
ses dernières lectures des conseils en
majorité ce sont des personnes âgées qui
ont recours à ce dispositif
mais les personnes handicapées femmes
enceintes ou encore souffrant d'une
pathologie peuvent aussi en profiter
ce matin-là une bibliothécaire cherche
des livres pour une personne âgée qu'il
a appelé un peu plus tôt en fait c'est
très important voyez le coup de fil
parce que ça peut être très bref c'est
la personne n'a vraiment des auteurs
c'est le mode et je veux le dernier
musso je veux lévy etc
là on peut passer très peu de temps
maintenant si c'est quelqu'un qui n'a
pas d'idées
c'est très important de prendre son
temps voyez à l'ennemi tu ne comptes pas
mon temps quand je suis au téléphone
parce que on essaye de trouver au mieux
ce qui correspond à ses goûts une fois
les livres trouver emmanuel de lille les
met dans un stack avec une liste de
questions pour affiner les recherches
futures
pour l'instant le portage de documents à
domicile se fait une demi journée par
semaine
arrivé chez la bénéficiaire la
bibliothécaire dépôt des livres sur le
pas de la porte
j'apprécie énormément collin porte à
domicile ça c'est assez agréable
d'autant plus que je commence à avoir un
peu de mal à marcher aller aussi loin et
j'ai l'intention d'en parler autour de
moi jusqu'à dix documents peuvent être
livrés toutes les quatre semaines
non